[Music]  exactly 50 GMT this polymers will catch  them don't they punished  it appears to a bit nothing more than a  warning major man in this 60s with a  grudge there's nothing everyone who's at  nine it's all been taken care of  you will change your mind  [Music]  there is every step of the way when the  old man running circles around the lot  of us why is it so hard  [Music]  it sounds like he's changed maybe  Special Forces  I'm guessing is made for bones you would  tell me who kill my child  [Music]  [Music]  you have no idea who you do  but you soon find out all coresight  standby standby go what if your wife and  daughter would kill by ball  you  [Music]  you